hot breath how how often were you going
up like what is
because we're i mean this is this is
dang cook this is bill bird
like you're gary goldman i know you were
waiting tables with at one time like
you're
you're with these superstars of comedy
like in the grind mode
of comedy before you're anything before
there's opportunities
like what did you know about hustle we
didn't know opportunities back then
we didn't know we weren't thinking about
tv we weren't thinking about
we weren't thinking about any of that
everybody want you know that's the
one thing we were just thinking about
getting on stage and being funny that's
all we were thinking about
where are we getting on stage tomorrow
stage time where are we getting on stage
it wasn't about five a year from now it
wasn't about
any of that we did whatever we had to do
job-wise
so that we could go and be on stage that
night
and do stand-up and then hang out for
hours and make each
other laugh that was the
that was it that was fine that was
enough how often were you on stage
every night every night every night we
could get on we were running we were
running from
you know driving a half hour to get on
stage do five minutes
and then flying to another club a half
hour away
to try to get on stage maybe not even
get on stage
we're running back and forth as much as
we can to get
on stage and we were going on stage
with some of the best comics in the
world like some of the funniest people
ever were hosting and on the show with
you
so you're following just murderers
people say why are boston comics good
because we had to be the stakes were
higher
we weren't in front of crowds
that were
you know our friends or
you know nice it was a bunch of boston
who paid money to laugh and then
you had
steve sweeney and kevin knox and don
gavin and joe yanetti and
all these guys on the show too so be
funny or
be gone there was no time
to not have your together
and have the confidence to get on that
stage and and and
so yeah it was it was crazy we went on a
lot man